Seit jahren wird davor gewarnt
und in diesem sommer scheint es offensichtlich so weit zu sein die tropenkrankheit mit dem namen west nil virus hat wohl den sprung über die
alpen geschafft in den letzten wochen hat das virus märz 800 menschen in südeuropa befallen und mehr als 70 von ihnen getötet
derzeit untersuchen noch experten und expertinnen mücken um genau diesen verdacht zu erhärten
wie den west nil viren wohl die
ausbreitung gelangen und wie gefährlich sie wirklich sind erfahrt ihr jetzt paar klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es täglich neue science videos
abonniert den channel sehr gerne herzlich willkommen
Das virus wurde
1937 erstmals in uganda entdeckt seit jahren kursieren die viren bereits südlich der alpen in diesem jahr haben sie beispielsweise in
kroatien und südfrankreich neue gebiete erobert verfliegen handfeste nachweise vor auch in den usa ist das virus mittlerweile verbreitet
und dass es nach deutschland kommt war wohl nur eine frage der zeit der
außergewöhnlich warme sommer mit der lang anhaltenden hitze hat wohl seinen teil dazu beigetragen dass sich der erreger in dieser saison so
massiv ausbreiten konnten als überträger der viren
kommen einige heimische arten von mücken in frage und diese haben in diesem jahr nicht nur besonders früh angefangen blut zu saugen
sondern auch besonders viele europäer
gefallen den hinweis darauf dass sich das virus auch in deutschland ausbreitet kommt aus halle an der saale dort war ein waldkauz
gestorben weil er eben genau diesen virus erlag
expertenteams wollen jetzt natürlich ganz genau wissen woher der erreger kann der die eule
getötet hat mücken fallen wurden aufgestellt und die gefangenen blutsauger in einem labor des friedrich loeffler instituts untersucht
insgesamt gibt es jetzt bundesweit drei nachweise von west nil fieber bei vögeln zwei davon in sachsen anhalt
beunruhigt sind die solchen teams weil der erreger auch auf menschen übertragbar ist und eben bisher in deutschland nicht heimisch war laut robert koch institut
gibt es bisher aber keine informationen über menschliche erkrankungsfälle an west nil fieber in dieser region das könnte aber auch an mangelnden
untersuchungen liegen beim menschen führt die tropenkrankheit
jedenfalls zu erbrechen kopfschmerzen und fieber in den meisten fällen fühlt sie sich also die eine gewinn ähnliche sommergrippe
nach angaben der weltgesundheitsorganisation
vero gibt es bei nur einem von 150 infizierten schwere komplikationen diese können dann aber auch zum tod führen doch klar ist auch
frühere ausbrüche können nicht wirklich zum vergleich dient dazu christina koch vom robert-koch-institut
das west nil virus ist stark unter
diagnostiziert heißt also im klartext weil die symptome der tropenkrankheit
denen der sommergrippe so ähnlich sind kommen viele ärzte teams gar nicht darauf nach diesen erregern zu suchen
das passiert meist erst wenn besonders viele vögel oder tiere in der region an den virus verändern und so ein
anfangsverdacht gegeben ist bisher gibt es weder impfungen noch medikamente die helfen können als schutz gibt es
chemischen abwehrmittel oder eben lange kleidung die nackte haut verdeckt die meisten der mückenarten die das west nil virus
übertragen stechen übrigens nicht nur in der dunkelheit sondern den ganzen tag über
fest steht aber die ansteckung läuft wohl über mücken und nicht durch den kontakt mit flügeln die infizierte mücken sind höchstwahrscheinlich mit
lastwagen oder mit güterzügen mit nach deutschland eingeschleppt worden jetzt wird darüber diskutiert ob
blutspenden dienste auch auf dieses virus testen sollen dieses bislang nämlich nicht in allen bundesländern
der fall und wenn ihr zu diesem und zu anderen themen kein video mehr verpassen wollt dann habe ich am ende des videos antrieb für
euch jetzt aber unser hochgestecktes ziel keine werbung mehr auf gigs und wir haben ja schon
angefangen immer mehr videos sind werbefrei dank eurer hilfe immer wenn wir entsprechen viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben
schalten wir die werbung vor einem video abwertet also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken
oder auf den link in der video beschreibung klicken und ihr bekommt noch exklusive extra videos live streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegierung für einen
und jetzt der trick wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
nur da bekommt er das aktuelle video deutlich vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken
und darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
erfolglosen von viren werden so gnadenlosen kindern bis dann
bleibt kann